let's talk about the idea of the
impedance of some simple networks now
what I've shown here there's a very
simple network it has two impedances in
it z1 and z2 and inside these boxes are
one of our favorite passive components
either an R and L or a C that's what's
in both of these things we're going to
look at combinations of this and figure
out what the impedance of simple
combinations are when we talk about
impedance what we mean is we take
sinusoidal signals we take a sinusoidal
voltage and divide it by a sinusoidal
current and that is that ratio is
impedance and so the voltage is
impressed across the two terminals here
and then the current the current I flows
this way so this will be I and this will
be plus or minus V between here and here
and the relationship between those two
things is called impedance so now we
have a circuit here with two impedances
in it in series they're connected in
series because they're head-to-tail now
if both of these impedances were
resistors like this if we just make them
resistors when we write down the
impedance of a resistor we just write
down our the vet the impedance of a
resistor is R and the impedance of this
one is R so we'll call that one r2 and
r1 and the overall the effective
impedance of the whole thing is
resistors in series we know this is r1
plus r2 so nothing new here yet now
let's make a little change let's do this
let's make a network that looks like a
resistor and a capacitor
and I want to know the voltage to
current ratio or I want to know the
impedance the effective impedance of
this so we transform this circuit we
write down this value is R and the
impedance of every of a capacitor is one
over J Omega C and if I want to I can
write it exactly the same way I could
say that is equal to minus J times 1
over Omega C remember 1 over J is the
same as minus J so if I want to know the
impedance of this network here Z is now
this is the great trick of doing this
transformation we can use the same laws
that we know for resistors on this
transformed circuit we transformed it
into the frequency domain so the series
combination of two impedances is the sum
of the impedances R plus 1 over J Omega
C this is the impedance of this network
here let's do another
let's do an inductor combination so
we'll do a resistor and an inductor like
that so the impedance of a resistor is r
the impedance of an inductor is j omega
l and i can write the combined impedance
of this the same thing it's a series of
peden s-- so I can do R plus J Omega L
now what I want to do next is is
introduce some new terminology that we
talked about impedances with so let's
look at these two examples down here for
the capacitor and the inductor r is a
real number 1 over J Omega C that's a
comp that say imaginary number and
together they make a complex number and
over here with the inductor we see the
same thing a real part and an imaginary
part so the way we write an impedance in
general as a rectangular complex number
is we say Z equals R plus and the letter
we use is X now R is the resistance and
X the name for X in general is reactance
X is the imaginary part of an impedance
and that's referred to as the reactance
we also talked about the inverse of
resistance 1 over resistance is called
conductance
that's that's 1 over R and 1 over X is
referred to as susceptance now these are
all just words that they all sound like
they sort of mean the same thing but
engineers wanted to have sort of
different words for different parts of
the of the impedance and these are the
words that we use and finally we have
another word for the inverse of
impedance the general idea of 1 over Z
and that's referred to as admittance at
MIT admittance this is a little
vocabulary we have admittance is the
opposite of impedance or the inverse of
impedance susceptance is the inverse of
reactance and conductance is the inverse
of resistance these are all just sort of
every word we can think of that that
meant that meant resist and let through
so now I'm going to roll up here a
little bit and we'll do some plots we'll
look more carefully at these at these
impedance expressions so if these are
all complex numbers that means I can
plot them on a complex plane so let's do
that and see what it tells us see if we
can learn anything ok if this is the
real and this is the imaginary now for
resistance to resistors we just have two
real parts so there's some Zi that's the
sum of two R's and that's a real number
so I would just get a some sort of value
like here like that all right add those
two vectors together and that would be Z
so let's do that for the the other
circuit now if I do it for capacitance
RC circuit the one resistor is out here
like this
that's a
value of our and see how do we plot C
well C remember is 1 over J Omega C is
the same as negative J times 1 over
Omega C so that's going to give us a
negative J it's going to give us a line
on the negative J axis here this real
imaginary and Z is going to be this
value here right there has a magnitude
of 1 over J Omega this point right here
has a magnitude the length of that
vector is 1 over Omega C and that point
right there when we do the vector e D
that will be Z right there depth at the
time like that now let's do the L let's
plot the the circuit that has an L in it
ok again we have an R so we go out some
distance R right there now J Omega L we
have a positive J here so it goes up by
Omega L so let's say L was kind of small
let's say it goes right there so that
has a magnitude of Omega L on the
imaginary axis and that will give us a
point that will be Z for that network
now you notice as let's say we change oh
may go let's say Omega is varying Omega
goes up in this case here Omega it goes
up this point will travel up it'll move
in the complex plane if Omega changes
this one if Omega changes if Omega gets
bigger for a capacitor if a mega gets
bigger for a capacitor that means that
this number gets smaller and this will
move in this direction and on the
resistor side if Omega changes well
there's there's no Omega term here so
nothing changes when Omega changes in
this resistor picture so this shows us
what happens in a graphical way when we
change the frequency
of a complex impedance now I want to do
one more let's do a circuit that looks
like this let's do three things let's do
an inductor a resistor and a capacitor
all in series and what is C so we label
it as we did before it J Omega L R 1
over J Omega C so let's now work out the
impedance of this it's a series circuit
so the impedance is ad so we can say
that Z equals J Omega L plus R plus 1
over J Omega C so we can try a plot of
these things here's the real here's the
imaginary let's do our first R is always
on the real axis some value like that J
Omega L goes up by some value here's the
inductor represented as a vector and
here's 1 over J Omega C that goes down
on the axis like that so it's going to
come down here somehow like this let's
make the capacitor small which makes its
impedance large the magnitude of that is
1 over Omega C and when we put all these
together we do basically we do a vector
add of these guys here so I can let's
move the L over here let's L goes up
like that there's a vector ad of L and
then I have a vector ad of this vector
here adds onto that back down like that
and the final answer is this guy right
here and this is Z for this network
right here is that complex number right
there and you see as we change Omega
different things happen and we can
basically move this point around moving
this point around with frequency is
basically the essence of AC analysis
we'll see you next time